good morning how bad is the NHS crisis
it's Saturday school
[Music]
and today Seoul student seems to be the
prime minister
part personal tutorial and part
published the opportunity Rishi sunak
seems to be replicating his Hands-On
approach to both the Autumn statement
and the small boats crisis by getting
expert briefings so he can try and sort
it out himself
ideas include using pharmacists better
at the moment we have a whole host of
Highly skilled professionals working in
our pharmacies we have our doors are
open they have always been open we can
play a large role in diagnosis similar
to how we did during the covert pandemic
and better controlling who comes and
goes from hospitals what we need to do
is to
work out ways to have fewer patients
come into Hospital who aren't going to
benefit from it and get people home
quicker at the other end and has that
meeting helped to do that uh I think so
there was a lot of senior clinical
leaders there and all of us were saying
exactly the same thing prime minister
seemed to understand that so we'll see
what happens
today's four Round Table sessions
focused on social care and delayed
discharge
urgent and Emergency Care elective care
operations which are not emergencies and
primary care including the role of GPS
and pharmacists Health experts and
clinical staff have been sounding the
alarm for years so it does beg the
question why it's taken Rishi sunak and
Steve Barkley so long to listen to them
while the experts talked patients seem
to be suffering with a critical incident
declared at hospitals in chertsey and
Guilford while in Warrington mixed views
on how to fix the Health Service let's
put the money where it's needed take the
money away from the politicians I think
everybody should give two pence out
their attacks every week
put it into the NHS straight into the
NHS let's just simplify it again the way
it used to be when you know 20 years 30
years ago
sources here say Rishi sunak is well
aware of problems within the NHS because
members of his extended family who work
in the Health Service told him all about
them over Christmas and while the
government's key Target to cut waiting
times is vague the decision of the Prime
Minister to put himself at the center of
sorting out this crisis is anything but
the danger if it doesn't work he will be
the face of that failure Joe Pike Sky
News Westminster